foreign
in Jacksonville Florida what's up Ashton
hi Dr John how are you good how are you
good thanks for taking my call of course
what's up
well I have almost like an iceberg of a
question initially it's fairly simple
but when
it just goes into so many facets of my
son in my life it just becomes more
complicated sure go for it so a quick
backstory I'm in my mid-30s I'm happily
married to my husband and we have two
children together
our son was born about 10 and a half
years ago and he was diagnosed with
cerebral palsy
he is doing amazing wow
we were told originally his prognosis
was he might never speak clearly he
might never walk without assistance and
he's overcome all those hurdles in these
past 10 years oh it's amazing
congratulations it's so cool
we we
have of supportive family we have
supportive church members
but it feels almost as if we live in
this in-between world
because he's doing so well
a lot of people can't tell initially
that he does have special needs
but he also does so well
that
he doesn't
necessarily uh I guess for lack of
better term fit in with children with
special needs
so
I'm just asking for some advice on how
to
help him navigate now that he's becoming
a teenager soon
we don't want him necessarily to fit in
but have the confidence
to know who he is
and know that while there are
limitations I mean it is a reality so
there's a there's another side to this
he doesn't fit in with
what we would traditionally think is as
a classroom with full of children with
special needs but that means he also
doesn't fit in with the kids running
around playing PE or football PE and run
around and you know like being a normal
jumping up and down so he's kind of
finding himself in no man's land right
exactly and he he started to realize
this recently and he mentioned to me the
other day that
he was feeling a little bit lonely
because you know the boys will run off
the play tag and he he can't do that but
he can still play sure
so um and um if it's okay with you
um
Kelly
the producer of the show has very
personal experience with this a very
similar situation with her son and I
would love to invite her on to her
expertise her lived expertise in this is
that okay
absolutely can I just share one more
little Factor absolutely you got it
okay so um my husband is in the military
and he's gone a lot like most military
members however when he's gone there's
no contact while he's gone okay there's
no phone calls no letters yep
and so I really it's really just me for
five six months of the year
so it makes it a little bit more
challenging in my opinion yes
um I'm gonna give you a a Meta Picture
that I'm gonna unpack here but I want
Kelly to speak into some of the very
specifics with your young one okay
um okay
foreign
it sounds like there is a fight going on
inside of you
between the way this should all look
versus the way it does
and here's how that unpacks
who who wouldn't want to be married to a
special ops guy who comes home and says
I'm going to save the world literally
can't tell you where or when but I'll be
home
and like that sounds so amazing
and then very romantic in a book that's
what I mean like in the movie when Chris
Pratt flexes and it's like oh I I I'm
like I'm Chris press looking pretty good
like I'm into it like so uh and then
also he's gone
and there's also month four
of
um Black Ops deployment
it's really lonely
and then there is the
two kids running around and
who wants to be having a conversation
with their kid about they can't and
can't do right and you're so grateful
that he's doing so good and he's beat
every prognosis
and yet we still need to have this
conversation because high schools middle
schools can be tough on a man right you
see what I'm saying and so there's
there's something to be set up for
the devastating
um you're gonna have to agree with at
some point
owning the reality this is my picture
and from there from from the choice to
own reality out of that is okay here's
what we can do here's what here's the
the conversations we can have the
support networks I need but I'm going to
live out of this because with my body's
still trying to solve for this picture
that's not real it's going to be hard
it's gonna it's gonna constantly feel
like you're at war with yourself or it's
that underlying it that burn of anxiety
that never stops that exhaustion right
because we're we're trying to make a
life happen this just isn't our reality
um so I'm gonna bring Kelly on here
um Kelly tell your story about Nathan
hey Ashton how are you all right good
good
um so I am a few years down the road
from you I have a 17 year old and he um
is um we adopted him when he was two he
has CP as well where yours is right side
of the body ours is lower half of the
body
um he walks with a limp we've had quite
a few surgeries and years of therapy
which I'm sure you know that
um oh we live at the therapist exactly
yeah it's like you might as well just
move in with them
um yeah a lot of physical therapy
um some surgeries that were
life-changing for us and but you know
it's still this is It's the reality we
live in it's his reality he still has a
limp there's still some things happening
um there's still a lot of things he
can't do so I understand we're going
with that and
so what you say you you talk about how
he's starting to question that is he at
the point where it's like I want to play
football I want to do that I want to do
these things
yes it is you know I want to do some
more things but even more so it's
um like in PE
you know he can participate to a certain
point right and he doesn't want to be
separated from his friends and I just I
think
so he actually is highly intelligent so
developmentally he's fine
yes there's no emotional or intellectual
delays he actually was gift a grade wow
because he is so intelligent which is
wonderful but now he's with even bigger
kids right that was I was about to say
that yeah that's probably it's a
double-edged sword there so let me ask
you let me ask both both moms here
um Kelly what what what is
is there a benefit to teaching him
um Sheila my wife calls it
exceptionalities that you've got some
differences
and I'm gonna teach you how to begin to
advocate for yourself both with your
friends and with the pet PE teacher and
that's going to be a part that's going
to be conversations that
you two moms will have that I won't have
with my son right right but it's just
it's it's it's teaching them to own the
reality right right we've we all we've
always been very very open about talking
about the disabilities because I've got
two kids with disabilities and about
that this is just you know your reality
and we talk we always say that the only
thing this gets you is better you know
parking at the front and better light
and you know front line at Disney which
it doesn't even get you that anymore uh
they took that away but um you know this
just gets you better parking you still
have to function in the world but it
does look different and there's
different ways you have to do things
does he have a um are you does he have
an IEP
uh no okay
we we go to a small Christian School
okay
and we chose that school because we can
speak directly with the teachers and
every year we just have a
like a document we saw at the school
with certain exceptions for him that
they will follow physical yeah I I would
tell you I hear this a lot and
I it's been my experience that often not
every time but public schools because
they have to they have to provide
resources by law
um often small private schools will roll
out of responsibilities or say well we
just don't do that or we can't help with
that when Public Schools absolutely 100
will because they have to by law and one
thing we found with very skilled workers
very skilled workers and other kids like
him
yes so that is that leans into that he
is doing so well
um we spent months we even actually had
to go through a legal process where
the city had said you know save these
services for a child who really needs it
oh my God what wow perfectly wow yeah
he's he's intellectually Advanced and
we're not looking for a legal battle I'm
yeah we're gonna do what we need for our
son you need to reach out to disability
rights
um uh Jacksonville uh I mean disability
rights Florida because that's that's
their purpose
nonsense crap like that
um okay let me get back to like just
okay sorry are you getting me all fired
up yeah I know that's where I want to go
with that but with the issues you're
dealing with does he have a group of
friends
yes at the school he does have a group
of friends good those especially those
boys are going to become your his
lifeline
um my son had the same group of friends
from kindergarten and we moved in high
school in
you know he's dealt with that he's done
it but we found out that when I dug into
those kids and you know they're how they
how that group worked because I was I
always had the fear that are they
getting left behind are they making fun
of him my son Falls a lot that's just
who he is he trips and he falls and they
just know they wait yeah every day it's
part of their world they just wait
they're like it's just Nathan it's what
he does and so those group of boys
um I I started a lot of having those
boys around not just in school we did
things with those boys that's who we did
birthday parties with it's who we had
over
um because I knew they were gonna there
they will start to protect him from
anyone else
uh because for them they're just like no
it doesn't matter it's just you know uh
whatever your son's name is it's just
him and they don't think anything
different
and we've started having to find because
my son did that well maybe I could play
basketball and you know in your heart
that's not gonna happen
you know and so it's not going to work
well possibly that could work what are
some other options if you don't do that
and now my son plays Esports which is
basically a glorified way to play video
games
um but it's where he's found his
community
it's where he's found as people and he
loves it and so relying heavily on those
boys and their families getting to know
their families and there are jokes that
my son will make about his disability
with his friends that I will tell you
make me cringe
but it's how he thinks they're funny
he's okay with it I always say you know
you just make sure you're okay with it
oh I think it's hilarious because it's
just who I am Mom it's not I'm not
hiding anything
my son's comedian too he yeah like if he
can't pick something up he'll be like oh
right he's not working today yeah and
you know my son does some DJ stuff and
he wanted to be be DJ crippled at one
point I was like no we're not gonna do
that we're gonna call a big no on that
but I've we've always with Nathan just
kind of let him lead
the conversation
um because
let him lead how he wanted to do it but
put plenty of options you know here's
the options and if you want to play
basketball buddy great you never know
you might find that coach that'll let
them do it but uh the way he's he sees a
counselor his counselor told me
something that really helped
let
we let us as the parents always be the
yes let the coach or the whoever be the
bad guy
if you want to play basketball bud great
let's talk to the coach
or if you want to play football and then
you get to hug them and hold them when
they cry because you know it's not going
to happen but you're the one that says
great I'm behind you if that's what you
want to do
but then when you know it's not going to
happen all right well let's look at
chess or
acting or whatever but that you that was
very helpful because
I my husband and I want to raise him as
he's just a person right he's Jinx you
know this this isn't it's a part of his
life but it's not it's not who they are
it's just you know it's just like I have
brown hair and it's important I always
encourage him I and I wasn't sure now
that if he's getting older I should say
no because I've just been doing what you
read recommended giving other options
and saying okay well we'll see what look
into it
and as he got into Middle School more we
had well why don't you go talk to the
coach kind of making him do it a little
more and then when he was like mom he
said you know that he doesn't think
it'll work okay well do you have any
interest in being the manager no okay
well then you know what when you cry
that's what I that's where I come in and
by the way for for parents that don't
have kids with special needs
um my sister was is a savant she's a
brilliant she's an academic decathlon
team my little brother missed like two
questions on the ACT and then there was
me the football player in the middle
right so my parents had to they had to
have different conversations every kid
is different that's right and so I think
it's backing out of your expectations
and dreams and wishes for this one and
saying who is this human being before me
and what special contribution can this
kid make to the world and what
limitations is this person going to have
and every kid's gonna have them children
with special needs are going to have
more pronounced ones that we can all see
but it but it's it's you can't clear
every obstacle right you just can't
because you're not you know he's gonna
have to live a life and you can just you
know you know we've told Nathan before I
can't clear this obstacle but I'll help
you figure out a way around it
and you know what can I I do to help you
and if you need me to advocate for you
if you need whatever I'll do it but it's
not just going to go away because it's
just part of the world they have to live
in the world still
but yeah absolutely
um as a child as a parent with a child's
special needs
um
I've seen all sorts of children in a
therapy if you go to the doctors and I
see so many families who have it
much more challenging and heartbreaking
than us
and
I struggle with feeling
almost
guilty using Services sometimes stop
stop with that get that out of here
right now don't ever feel guilty Felicia
with that yeah that's done you get you
cannot compare tragedy right you can't
compare
um pain you can't compare individual
circumstances
your reality is your reality there are
plenty of services you need them for
it's not some zero yeah there's not just
a you know a pie and this is all we get
you know there's only so many services
you have as much right to those Services
because you're advocating for your child
so yeah you got to let that one go
because because we've just we've gotten
our child everything that had been
recommended it's just we've
you know had to go through several
locations to try and find someone who
would give it to us without us having to
fight them right and and that's that's
because we live in a messy ugly and
sometimes you will have to fight them
yeah and that's okay because you there
are Services I hate to use the word
entitled but that you have the right to
but don't ever feel guilty and I mean
like there's times with you know like
hey the handicapped parking spot there's
one four down from that that we could
take and Nathan's like I'm fine walking
that Mom I can do it okay great we'll do
that you know and not take up that spot
in case somebody needs it but yeah you
got to let that that guilt go that yes
there are
again we don't compare tragedies there's
different versions everybody's fighting
their own battle so yeah that you're
doing what you got to do for your boy
okay smile smile big smile big and and
for whatever it's worth
um I've I've taught at the University
level at the highest level with doctoral
students and I've taught
um law students so I've been in across
the board here right or I'm gonna say I
taught law students serve law students
um
hahaha
the opportunities for your child are
going to look different but the the
world is is open for them right and so
let that let that little boy be who he's
gonna be and be the be the fuel in his
jet pack not the GPS system telling him
where he's gonna go does that make sense
yes yeah two other things hold on I want
to say real quick
um
not a bad idea maybe to start a
counselor we started a counselor with
our son about maybe 12 10 12. because
there's going to be some anger issues
and there's going to be some things he
doesn't want to talk to you about
so we actually just started Council
perfect for him that is I wanted to find
a man who and that's what we are be
there that's what we did and it was
great and it's been in Nathan's 17 and
he still goes once a month and he loves
it so that's a great thing to put in
place and then
learn to be the sounding board when he
comes home and says mom it really sucked
today because they played basketball and
I couldn't do it you can't fix that
remember that you can't fix it but you
can sit there and go wow that must have
really hurt
tell me about it
can I hug you yeah you want a hug or you
know whatever you can't fix them all and
sometimes you just have to sit there and
go I'm sorry
yeah but I I'm sorry that really does
suck
and can I challenge you and husband
yes
um this is easier for me to say because
it just doesn't apply to me at this
moment in my life
I would love to challenge your husband
to every week he's home write a letter
and put it in an envelope that's undated
so that every week he's gone
your two kids get a letter from Dad
telling them how much he loves them how
special they are how
um like an exciting memory he might have
that's not um that he can that he could
share a piece of or something but that
they are getting something
um some sort of communication some sort
of reach out and five years from now ten
years from now 25 years from now
the effort the kids will will understand
what links their dad went to
um to make them feel special and seen
and loved even when he was out uh
fighting evil in the dark
I think that'd be a cool thing
that's a great idea we're definitely
gonna
Implement that
that won't be fun for him I know but uh
man I think the I think the gifts long
the downstream to your kids would be
magical but all in all
um Kelly thank you so much for your
wisdom and insight there uh
thank you for being a great mom Ashton
thank you for being a great mom and
congrats to your son for just continuing
to defy the odds
um
I love the idea of every parent sitting
back and asking themselves not what can
I make my kid do
what what what is my kid capable of
who is this person in front of me
what are they into what do they love
what are the things we need to Rally
around them right so if your kid is all
into theater and choir that's incredible
you're gonna have to be help with with
movement with I think I want you to play
soccer I want you to we're going to go
outside and go for walks together
because movement's important and if your
kid is just jocked 2000 let's go crush
them in cool
um I want you to take uh piano or violin
too like I'm it's it's our job to round
out our kids
but it's not our job to say you will end
up here
I'm telling you
can't count the conversations lots of
them
kids in their fourth year of grad school
or finishing up a PhD or finishing up an
undergrad degree
saying I absolutely hate my life and I'm
only doing this because Mom and Dad said
this is what you're right they they
force me into a path
um
moms and dads love our kids and Ashton's
just setting a great example for her
little one thank you so much for the
call Ashton we wish you guys the best
holidays if I can ever help and thank
you and your husband for your service
and um
for all those that are out on Ops that
none of us know about except for the
husbands and wives sitting at home with
their jaw clinched we're grateful for
you